We have our dispatch quiz. Let's look at the solution.
If this instruction was indeed issued in the previous cycle,
meaning it came into the reservation station. Then, depending on,
when do we select [INAUDIBLE] instructions for execution. Let's say we do it,
kind of, you know, towards the end of the cycle. There might not be enough time.
Simply, this reservation station, when we're considering,
what can be dispatch for execution. This one simply wasn't there yet, basically.
In the same cycle where we select something, this got inserted here and it
wasn't inserted early enough in the cycle, so this is possibly correct. It can
happen that's, that's basically you cannot do both of the things consecutively
in the same cycle. Another instruction was dispatched to the add unit. This is
entirely possible if, for example, RS1 will sent. In the previous cycle to,
to the execution unit, then this instruction couldn't have because then it can,
can't take only one instruction. So this is also possibly correct.
RS2 is older than RS3, so RS3 cannot dispatch until RS2 does.
This cannot be correct. Because, in out of order execution in [UNKNOWN]
algorithm is one of the out of order algorithms, we will dispatch an instruction
as soon as its operands are ready. If we were concerned about this,
when the operands are ready, we still don't dispatch the instruction, then we
will have an in-ordered processor, which we don't want. Actually, the reason why
this is an out-of-order processor is because, is that instructions like this can
execute even if they are not the oldest instruction in the reservation stations.
So this is definitely not true. So the correct answers are only one and two.